hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica thanks
for waiting patiently for this episode I
had some stuff to take care of but these
videos will be coming out more regularly
from now on every three to four days
until the end of the current content
I've got new members of the change but
I've got new people to put on the
lockers here first off is Oh Oh DC
sniper oh oh three and then there's
Keiichiro senpai and Mary Berg and I'm
gonna read what they say while I go on
the way to where I'm supposed to be
going because I don't want to wait too
much time in getting there because I've
got a lot of stuff to do so before
actually get going here let me just go
let me back up a second I feel like
we're getting a little rushed here I
have with me two ion crystals that I
thought would be generally important to
take with me because if I don't have a
purple artifact at the other place I can
make a purple Arvelo phone well because
the recipe is an ion crystal and two
diamonds which I forgot to pull out of
the goddamn thing okay here we go why am
i there excuse me don't warp me please I
don't want to be warped no no no that's
bad alright so warp you were P I have I
have a buttload of diamond because I've
got nothing but riches and no friends to
my name oh you know diamonds are a nice
close second to actual real people to
have a human connection with alright so
now that I got diamonds I can actually
and I believe I got four of them right
I've ever gone four of them but in
before of a mama goddamn idiot yes I did
it okay so I got four of them and two
ion crystals which means that I can make
a maximum of two purple artifacts to be
able to do that so I'm gonna pile it on
my way back first to my original base by
the Aurora
you better not follow me over there I
don't think he goes that far away but
Tess in case you never know with these
but I'm gonna go back to where
the first base was because there I
believe I have a purple artifact and on
the way I'm gonna read what people say
so
Oh Oh DC sniper oh oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey hey there floating island house
a little bit close yeah I love you and
everything but you need to get the Frick
away from me all right so here Oh DC
sniper 0:03 says mark here all the
coordinates to the alien caches if you
go to a big coordinate you will find a
crater in it go through a few caves
that's more story that you can read
about the precursors you will need a
purple artifact to get in though there
are more places like the one I just
mentioned in the sparse reef which is
where I'm going or at the Blood kelp
which I didn't even know there was one
over there I don't know where the first
coordinate is I don't even know how to
use the coordinates to be able to go
where I need to go I don't know if
that's an in-game thing or if I'd have
to cross-reference mapper try to find
some way to I don't know I have no idea
how to find it but I'm gonna do my best
because that's very very helpful but
they say please do note the first
coordinate that I mentioned may or may
not rely on an event to show up so it
may not be there but the two should
definitely be there also there's a lot
of ion crystals in those places you will
need a perfect purple artifact reach so
that's good news because then I can get
the ion crystals from those and it's not
a terrible waste of using the ion
crystal just to be able to get the other
item that I need now I just realized how
dumb I am because I'm taking my Cyclops
over to my first base instead of my
seamoth which is just damn stupid
because I kind of forgot that I
Yeah right coming in here okay well I
wasted a bunch of everybody's time
ah well if it wouldn't be a
markiplier blade the roof something
didn't go horribly wrong right at the
beginning of and I regret all my life
choices and everything light laugh
that's cool all right
anyway moving on I'm committed I'm stuck
to this it's not gonna waste any your
guys this time it's just gonna waste
mine next up is catchy row senpai who
said the developers should put in an
area that's pitch black so you need a
flashlight to explore it and a creature
that would stock you in the dark but if
you flash it it'll back away what would
make it better as if the dark place was
a key component to getting farther in
the game you'd love that wouldn't you
Mark Blair oh yeah I would
oh there's one thing this game needs
more it's horrifying creatures in the
darkness of the ocean dude bite my ass
off and show it to me before I die I
don't want any of that so that sounds
horrible so that sounds something like
the developers are actually gonna do
I've got a lot to be afraid of already
and I don't need more on my plate that's
just gonna haunt my dreams I have
trouble enough going to sleep knowing
that all the friends are dead everyone I
knew and loved and even hated on the
Aurora's blown smitheroons are eaten by
fishes and reaper loved athens that's
all right I'm coping got my diamonds in
my uranium and my ion crystals that's
good that's good my next up is Mary burg
who actually said a lot of very very
very useful advice here so they said
before you start hoping to reach the
lava castle you need to prepare yourself
you can actually bring the seamoth prawn
suit below the breaking point but you
don't need to take them out they will
explode outside the Cyclops it's a good
idea to have a repulsion cannon to
remove the power sucking slugs but a
knife will do I didn't know there were
gonna be power sucking slugs down there
but good to know that's a thing that
happens it's good to have a thermometer
so you know when your blood starts to
boil also good advice and they said you
need a heat-resistant suit which I
didn't even know that was a shoot you
could make but apparently it makes sense
considering you start earning alive when
you're near lava vents
then dad you probably need the kiddie
poster to protect you from loneliness
which I'm gonna do because my kitty
poster is right over here and somehow I
forgot it where is it wait did I hang on
my kid even know I'm a kitty post it
down there I see you in there which is
the weird superpowers that I have to see
through a bear's
walls and then they said you will need
bravery so you don't freak out when the
secret dragon Leviathan tips your
Cyclops over you need to know that the
sea dragon is instant death if you get
out and see it alone great
good I mean if you were alone and I bet
the Reaper Leviathan is also instant
death but you know I have not seen the
sea dragon Leviathan face-to-face in
actual gameplay I saw it in the
developer I don't think I want to see
how terrifying it actually is up close
and personal so oh wait no I did get
eaten by it before huh so I'm used to
this experience nothing too great I can
get eaten all day long oh and then they
said and most importantly the sea dragon
Leviathan can't hurt you when you're in
your Cyclops and that's all the plasteel
ingot scaping me safe from everybody and
hiding my emotions away from everybody
that can see inside my fragile soul so
ah screw you guys to try to peer into my
empty loneliness you'll never see the
light of day just like all my friends is
they're dead anyway
what was I talking about oh yeah I was
going down here oh also um a lot of you
guys I didn't get a specific name but I
just saw this a lot of you guys said
that the power charger in our Power Cell
charger in the Cyclops isn't actually
cheating because it's due to the heat
compensation module so the heat
compensation module is what reabsorbs
I product heat from the ambient energy
of the Cyclops and that recharges the
power cells so when you have a Power
Cell charger it's running off of that
50% efficiency so technically speaking
it's infinite energy but it makes not a
lot of sense but it makes enough sense
that I'm going to use that cuz I'm
desperate and I'm about to die so I need
to find purple artifact if it's not here
gotta make it
Oh kitty poster you're gonna keep me so
common darkest tonight's cuz y know when
all my friends are dead you'll still be
not a
but close enough to approximation
that'll make me feel better about myself
and that's all that matters right guys
right Doku peeper hey how long have you
been there yeah I'll eat you I'll cook
you up yeah I'll do that for you
lithium don't need that salt don't need
that is there no did I take it out of
there where would I put it if I did I
have no idea well is my see glide oh oh
and a full power so I want another pull
full full of power so good too bad I
can't unmake these things because I
could use the materials ooh building
them I need a battery charger - but I'm
just dumb so I'm not gonna do that
focusing on one thing at a time guys one
thing at a time all right so what have
you got for me where do you have for me
kick me this paper I need it in Bellotti
give me that give me the beep that's a
tasty P not yet but here it is let's
compete so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna do a ballsy move here because
there's a fabricator right here and if
you know about a fabricator it has
certain components but its component
built by the Builder builder and I can
deconstruct that son of a and get
out of it titanium titanium computer
chip and a wiring kit and if you know
what a power cell generator needs to be
built for power it is cuz you know man
wait a second we're getting there
everybody hold on your horses exactly
all that thing that I said that that was
bet you didn't know how smart I was and
the answer is beer so with that being
said and my voice cracking and due to
puberty I'm gonna go back out there
in the middle of the night and I'm gonna
build me a gosh-darn power cell charger
I'm gonna use it until they patch it out
make sure that don't work all systems
online or just your joint
on you Shane well that's not correct
that's the one to one of my news I'm
gonna fill it with the power cells at a
guy ooh
six-six-six power well it's good because
I'm about to summon a demon to be able
to power all the that I need I'm
not by my mom mom gonna put this right
that looks good to be it's dark in here
but because of this I'm going to be able
to put these in here right there and
then they are going to share our route
right ah-ha-ha-ha-ha
see they're charging very slowly but I
don't think it's gonna be any slower
than I already am running my ship so
with that being said they will charge I
will get power and I will win I don't
know what I'm gonna win but I think
something along the lines of me winning
isn't pretty pretty close to what I
should be talking about here anyway I
think I can turn the internal lighting
on now oh that was a bad spot to put
that button oh well I'm not very smart
about where I place things so I don't
even know if the batteries actually were
drained by the lights or nothing better
safe than sorry that's the markiplier
motto I'm gonna dump some stuff down the
bottom let's see who's gonna get a lot
of stuff see how about you take these oh
yeah and the purple artifact wasn't
there so I must have used it on
something but either way I can make it
so with this I need the advanced
material no sustenance probably not is
ah here we go so I'm gonna use one just
one for now I don't know if I'm
underneath an eye on crystal later but
I'm gonna use this one for now lemma and
then that's gonna make me a purple
artifact which is gonna be able to get
me into the one I'm only gonna go to the
one in the Hearts reef address the dude
stuff whatever it was called to do he
goes go to the dunes but this isn't I
think Oh the first coordinate must be
the one in the dunes but I'm gonna go
there and if it's not there I'm gonna go
to the other ones but we shall see no I
think I'm good for now hair mundane 33
UT you keep these
keep them closed because I'm very scared
I got to put the keep kitty poop I got
to put the keep Kitty poster keep calm
Kitty poster is gonna be right you know
can I put it there I want it right by me
watching over me as I drift off into
madness
oh why can't I put it here no oh no this
is an injustice this is sad
developers I can't put a keep calm Kitty
pusher down here in my psyche but I love
him but I love him oh this is malarkey
okay you know what I'm gonna do the next
best thing
and I'm gonna keep this in my inventory
till the end of my days good sir till
the end of my days he'll be here in my
heart with Oh anyway so I think this is
going to be the end of my need to come
back here second base thank you for
being so providing for me in my early
stages here in the ocean I can't believe
I'm actually feeling a bit sad about
this in my early stages here in the
ocean you really did help me along in my
first journey I had a lot of memories in
you and it seems so long ago now that I
first built you found this little nook
in and I I'm literally getting emotional
here but you know when I first went into
the Aurora and I didn't know what to
expect and there was a lot of unknown
variables there you really stuck by me
that means a lot to me and I just wanted
to tell you that I always think of you
even as I go down deeper into the into
the world I know that if I ever need to
come back here if I ever need to go to
the Aurora then you're gonna be just as
dependable as you always happen that
means a lot to me so
well this is a goodbye it's not a
goodbye forever hopefully so goodbye
first base I'll always remember you and
I'll think of the the warmth you
provided me and my darkest moments down
sorry sorry I'm trying to say some here
getting very emotional you're getting in
the way of my emotions I don't like that
just want to say I'll remember you and I
think our experiences together are gonna
help me find myself in the darkness okay
we're flying again
well okay well this is interesting I
don't know what I'm stuck on but could
it get off my ass could it could it just
you know unlock itself from between my
cheeks Oh a wreck it's really I'm stuck
in a oh I'm stuck on one girder all
right
fine then fine okay I get I see how this
is see how this is we I'm flying I'm
flying well I actually am flying now
that's a that's a unique feature
that's a strange there's a strange
sensation to be flying right literally
all right all taking you know whatever
guess we're above water now yeah and are
we sinking are we going back into the
ocean or is this just you know what I
should expect from now I shouldn't go
into the deep jowls again the showers
again wherever I was thinking it going
can we go down now there we go alright
now we're back into the thick of it so I
actually I actually did get a little
emotional I got a little emotional
I'll miss that bass that was a good bass
I was 100% a good bass I love that bass
it was good to me now my life bought
that thing Frick it to death I
don't even want to know its name which I
never learned cuz I don't care oh whoa
whoa whoa dude whoa dude okay how's
weird
hey Basia why is everything flying these
days thanks for trying to leave the
planet I don't
yeah things Ryan to leave the plan I
don't know how or why but uh seems the
creatures of this planet are learning
how to escape the planet's gravitational
oh all right so if I'm not mistaken
seamoth is over there but I need to go
pretty sure I'm going the right
direction because oh hey hey no none
come on now don't be like that it's if I
look good looking looking looking up
that way okay so that's over there so
I'm pretty sure pretty sure pretty sure
if I just go a little bit do it I should
have made a compass a long time ago what
does it take to make a compass actually
and let me look at that before I go any
further
exactly definitely be helping me compass
copper wire and computer chip that's a
lot of crap that I don't need to waste a
thermometer here chips huh
oh yeah that's where I'm going I'm going
to the dunes to mine some silver I
needed a lot of that Oh amazing how
these things should work out when you
don't remember anything that you're
gonna do and then you just end up
falling into the place where maybe isn't
that a great way to go about life I
think it is complete and utter ignorance
that's me
middle name mark lien utter ignorance of
life let's be okay let's dive and see
what we're dealing with you're whoo
hello rocks okay so we're in the friend
the grasslands I think it's called and
so I know that's a ship record
that's not what we're looking for I'm
pretty sure I've seen that before many
times
loading seems to be a lot better I will
admit loading is a lot better than has
been in the past oh yeah that's one with
crash life bought okay so this is good
because I'm pretty sure if I just go a
little due north from here because I'm
headed west on the map and to get to the
dunes it's past this area but just north
of the the great reef the grand reef or
whatever you want to call it and it's
actually just past this other area
called the UH the Striders walk or
something the walkers the tripods what
the elephant creatures walk whatever it
is I don't know oh no oh I know where I
am
I built the base here before right below
me would be the mushrooms so I'm heading
a little too north then but I know this
area I should have built my base again
here because this was a great launching
point for everything that I needed there
was tons of materials there was silver
all over this place why did I ever leave
why didn't I build it here again I'm a
fool that's why cuz I've grown unwise
with my age sama gosh darn idiot but at
least I know where I am
so yeah the mushroom forest would have
been a much better place for me to stake
my claim because that would have been a
good launching point because the grand
reef is right over there
the dune is right over there the
entrance to the inactive lava zones
right over there I know where all they
are and yet I didn't do that because I
wanted something new and to make it hard
for myself and live in darkness till the
end of my days how's my thought process
my man hope I clarified there for you
anyhoo you illustris oh my god are those
the silver double oh hey nice dick okay
that was that jutted out of nowhere okay
but I'm in the right place because that
I believe is silver and with silver I'll
be able to make all the computer chips
and that I need so I want to go
there and mr. Pfister and hopefully no
one's gonna meet me on the way down
there let me get another Wawa good how
you doing
getting there 50 percent not bad not bad
I'm gonna I'm gonna get back to you I'm
gonna build another one of you guys
before the end of my time here I need to
take mr. Pfister out for a little ride
welcome aboard indeed ah so nice down
here wants to owe you sack bass get out
of my face I don't have any time for you
I got Grandon to do oh and I also know
that if I take the grappling arm off I
do know that I'll be able to grab it
with just mr. Pfister and that'll be
my inventory I do know that what reason
I'm not doing that it's cuz the
grappling hook is my only link to sanity
when I'm trying to travel any sort of
distance if I didn't have that I would
lose my goddamn mind finally I'm just
gonna grind it up and then collect it
all later
oh it's the boon it's the boon of my
entire existence yes
oh my god it's so much Oh
Larry did you hear earth warps Tash did
you hear we've got silver I've got
silver I'm gonna grind you in a sack of
ass also the grappling hook is great a
great warp stash deterrent oh yes oh yes
I've got so much oh this is a dream come
true I know I know I should have known
that about this before I know I was
going the hard route of not doing this
but it's still so rewarding have it here
now wait come on the crap out of you
oh what's that you don't like grounded
me you don't like grounded you get out
of here this is my silver you can't take
my claim all right got it nabbed it oh
my inventory is gonna be full of silver
yeah okay so how much do I got now
there's so much yes okay I think that'll
be enough for now it's never enough at
least he'll be enough for me to do what
I need to do now if only I knew hey
how's it going warps ass you want to get
ground into a piece of that you are
Oh later I do wrong please let me redo
that egg exit wrong place later ah still
of warp Adam welcome up cool I'll come
back to you are now and I'll come back
to you when I'm wilted smarter hot so
now that I got all the silver in the
world which is amazing I can make pretty
much any electronic that I need wiring
kids computer chips which I need table
coral for but I saw some of it back
there and a little bit of quartz so all
these are basic materials there's even
giant quartz deposits right here so I'm
in good shape
John I'm gonna do
so I'm gonna farm a bit more yeah I
think I'm gonna do that yeah I'm gonna
farm a bit more I'm gonna fill my
inventory I'm gonna drop off my silver
who's gonna be silver Locke five yeah
your silver no why am i doing lockers
here when I got lockers here our
creation your silver you're in charge of
all the silver ain't no fly off from me
come back here almost eight whoa oh you
got another one in there for you weren't
gonna double bang off for me class right
I believe you all right and now I know
it's an inefficient way of doing things
but I might do it anyway all right
that's a lot of quarts hey I missed you
over there did you miss me baby okay
don't don't bite me please don't bite me
please all right got this I should be in
a way yeah you thought I missed you
didn't you whoo good now I've got some
good bit of material so what I'm gonna
do is I'm not quite ready to stop
farming now uh this is like my one
moment to get as much silver in courts
as possible and I'm gonna have Mariel em
be the quartz master and then I should
have everything I need to keep going
forward in the game but unfortunately
I'm all out of time on this episode
don't worry there's gonna be more
regular episodes coming soon with steady
marching progress as I slowly slip into
madness which is always a fun adventure
for me each and every time I get to do
it so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how to find this
alien cache specifically from where I am
I'll see you thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye-bye
[Music]